>> John: HERE IS CHABOT.
ADAM GAUDETTE WITH A CHANCE, ANA
BACKHANDS, AND THAT IS THE ONE
THING IF YOU ARE A DEFENSEMAN AT
THIS POINT.
KEEP HIM ON
MUCH.
>> John: HERE IS ARTEM ZUFORWAR.
DRYSDALE.
>> Jamie: THAT IS THE GOOD.
ONE
GETS KIND OF TURNED OVER BY
LINDHOLM.
PAD OF FORSBERG AND I COME ACRL
OF A SUDDEN HE
IN.
>> John: 27 GAMES WITHOUT A ZUB.
THOMSON.
SLIDES IT ON
>> John: HOW ABOUT THATNG TEAM.
THIS IS JUST A REAL SOLID PASS.
A GUTSY PASS UP
ENNIS.
A LITTLE TOO TIGHT TO THE WING.
TIM STUTZLE CUTS TO THE MIDDLE.
PLAY OFF SIX OFON THE LOOSE PUC.
DRIVING THE N THEY CAN.
HE HOLDS THE LINE.
IT'S A
12-SHOT MARK THE OTHER NIGHT GU.
WHWH FOR FORMENTON
AROUND THE NET.
LOST THE HANDLE ON
THAT.
TKACHUK.
FORMENTON.
YOU MENTIONED THE FIV,
DID SOME CRAZY, REGAIN THE LEADE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE.
ENNIS.
STUTZLE SOKOLOV.
A GREATT ONE.
>> John: DUCKS TRYING TO
EXTEND THEIR LEAD BY TWO.
BUT THE POINT FOR CHABOT.
STUTZLE
TO PEPPER ANAHEIM.
STUTZLE THROWS THIS TO THE NET.
PAUL GETS